many animals make things that are beauty
but now we don't know if they step back
and appreciate that beauty we make art
we create and that's something very
unique to humans and say there's
something in that that is important to
also tapping into these deeper layers of
our mind in our heart and our our body
consciousness our body memory about
trauma and how do we work through those
things so they're not stuck boom what's
up everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake and we are at
consciousness hackings awakened future
summit we are now gonna be talking to
East Forest hello hello
thank you so much for coming on the show
really appreciate it yeah very like this
is a music centric show musics a show
they're set up pieces of piano actually
East performed today in the morning in
tomorrow
yeah but morning bulls are like starting
today Sammy it is starting the day with
ceremony and it was just it was
beautiful unlocking for so many people
and nesting for so many people
a composer producer musician an artist
you know we'll have we have some of that
b-roll from from the from what you did
this morning embedded here for people to
view east let's start with who are you
and what do you stand for Who am I as an
artist because otherwise it's a bigger
question I don't have the answer to as
an artist with empty East forests which
I suppose sometimes becomes my identity
I'm interested in how music can take us
on an inner journey how it can take us
inside and so I also interested in the
technology of ceremony and how we can
use ritual to also do the same thing so
sort of an inner journey through music
and ceremony and bringing those things
together and that's just something I've
been interested in for a long time
because I had experiences with music
they think many of us have had where we
might have stumbled into mystical States
whether it's with a psychedelic or
through meditation or just whatever a
static States and I didn't have any real
guidance or teachers and so over time
about ten years now I've just been
developing my own musical language that
works for me I think it works for some
other people now it looks like too but
it's just what works for me and I wanted
to find reliable ways to get into those
sort of infinite mystical States and so
I'm very interested in psychedelic
assisted therapy and how the role music
plays in that or how we can do it in a
very public setting like what you
experienced this morning we can do it
when I call you so forth ceremony that's
essentially a mixture of concert and
ritual it's not complicated but it can
be very emotional because felt
experiences are things that people can't
argue with whoever you are across the
board what you have is what you have
it's not something I told you or
proselytize or an idea we put in your
head it's something you experience
you've created a musical language that's
very unique is it well I mean speak to
us about it's unique because it so for
those who didn't don't know what it is
it's sort of patient right and it's made
with a lot of pianos and loop
in nature field recordings and sort of
vocals that don't have a lot of lyrics
but these vocalizations are singing and
samples of things that I also feel
recordings of recordings whether it's
ROM das or something but what's unusual
about it is it came out of ten starting
ten years ago me guiding psilocybin
ceremonies and I needed to find a way to
guide people practically by myself for
five six hours so that's where the
looping came from and that's where the
slow progression of songs slowly
building and that sort of musical
language and lexicon developed out of
that because I was just sort of
exploring just what works what works to
give people a positive journey and so
over anecdotal research over all those
years it was sort of just trying things
and of course it's my own musical taste
but I wanted to create a musical
language that's like a new shamanic
American path their music one that
speaks to our Western ears and one that
is very understandable and approachable
to the way we understand music in the
West so it's it's comfortable it's a
comfortable space because we know set
and setting is very important to having
a good journey and so just last Friday I
released an album called music for
mushrooms a soundtrack for the
psychedelic practitioner and it's a
five-hour record from those spaces as
the first time I put something out that
was specifically for psilocybin drinking
it was aiming it at the research studies
going on of course it could be used for
anything and I think it's time I think
it's time to put stuff out like that and
I'm also doing a record with ROM das
over this whole year Congrats yeah what
I recorded to him last year and that's
also about tapping into wisdom because
he's 88 and and it's a reflection of the
wisdom that maybe we put aside in our
culture these days but is needed now
more than ever
whether it's wisdom from plant medicine
or wisdom from our elders especially the
ones who have a lot to say so beautiful
man there's so much here the the
language that that you've picked with
your music you've gave a couple
descriptions piano field recordings I
love that and it's when when you hear it
it it it and you said the sentence
setting as well is so critical to the
experience we had a dark space we had
some beautiful lighting choices we had
some we had some moves at Sage that was
burned before it yeah by some sage and
Palo Santo again it's a set and setting
yeah
and ceremony is a way of telling your
mind and your heart your body okay this
is important so kind of priming your
subconscious to say let's get into those
deeper layers and plant some seeds and
that's that's these are some of the
tricks of ceremony it's not voodoo I'm
saying we're actually working we're
getting into a trance state which makes
your unconscious or subconscious more
receptive to these ideas this is sort of
like hypnosis or something this stuff
works and so we're doing these things
it's also very beautiful but I think the
beauty is something that makes us unique
as humans we appreciate that beauty I
mean we are the ones that say it's
beautiful but that's like many animals
make things that are beauty but now we
don't know if they step back and
appreciate that beauty we make art we
create and that's something very unique
to humans and I'm saying there's
something in that that is important to
also tapping into these deeper layers of
our mind in our heart and our our body
consciousness our body memory about
trauma and how do we work through those
things so they're not stuck and so I'm
kind of exploring that in a brain body
approach but doing it in a very creative
artistic way and it's something that
again I just sort of stumbled in for my
own it's my own interests but it's it's
it's kind of been a lab or an experiment
and it's it's been changing every time I
do when we try new things and I'm
excited to see where it could go because
I feel like it's very universal and
approachable how do you argue with music
there's no lyric oh he's you know
talking about the the dolphin the
dolphin this or are they yeah you know
the crystal starship this that there's
nothing like that so I want it to be
something anyone could walk into and
it's just cultivating emotions in you
prime people with Dom Beyonc like you
said and and they choose really go in
their minds and how I was saying yeah
offering questions what makes you want
to give up in this moment is there
something do you notice a feeling right
now pay attention to it maybe you don't
all right so it's just setting the stage
in this tick you all the way to the
recent album recording yeah called
mushroom music for mushroom music : a
soundtrack for the psychedelic
practitioner not yeah which is sort of a
sister record inside the ROM das east
forest record that's been going on all
year okay okay because Rob das is you
know he or if you don't know he's that I
kind of call him the psychedelic
grandfather right country in a sense
came in Tim Leary so they're all sort of
related mmhmm yeah so so now you have
said a couple times throughout the
conversation and part and the album
itself written even for psychotherapy
sessions and sang about this this is a
good thing yeah so then what is your
what is your perspective then on the
role of psychedelics in the in the
experiences also that you curate in the
awakening that is currently happening
mm-hmm do you mean how do I see that may
be occurring inside the things I'm doing
yeah well what I'm this is for a
ceremony concerts for obvious reasons do
not involve our condo and psychedelic
ingestion during them because it's not
legal and moreover it takes a long time
so today we use cacao and that was
something we did here so it's sort of a
one-off currently for this because they
wanted to try using something medicinal
and psychoactive and so we can go in
that direction I think at this point
kind of thinks people are responsible
they they do what's right for them maybe
people come in and they've eaten Apple
or they've trip they've ingested some
form of psychedelic but I can't hold
that responsibility because it's not
really that kind of space it's only an
hour and a half or two it's not
overnight and that sort of thing but the
cultural winds are moving to a place
where that might become feasible
actually in the near future where we
really could in a public way have a very
strong container and hold space for
people instead of being the private
shadows as many people are as
practitioners but guide people in that
way because as anyone knows he's worked
with psychedelics it's it's very serious
for me and it's it's it's a not a toy
and it can be powerful in any direction
and so I take I take I don't take that
lightly and so I'm not saying hey we
sure yeah I should come in and take
psych as I say the opposite to say I
don't think this is a space for that but
I'm also so you're all adults and it's
just semi free country but it's not
legal that's the role though at your
live performances but then you did the
recording for those yes explain that
well the recording is I know it is a bit
of a juxtaposition but the recording is
for the work and the reason it's five
hours and the way it's designed and how
it's connected and instrumentation and
all and I could go on and on to what's
happening in the album but it's
specifically designed to help a
psilocybin journey would it work for
MDMA LSD probably but I know it's
designed would work for yoga what worked
for studying yeah I would guess so but
I'm just saying that's why everything in
it is the way it is and I did that
because I was looking at the music
that's currently being used in a lot of
the research studies because they've
published the playlist like John Hopkins
or Imperial College I wasn't personally
satisfied with them and I know the I
know that a lot of the music they're
using and I saw reasons why I thought it
could be better and I also had my own
experience I had I had
my own personal solution I hadn't given
it to the world so I was like no one's
putting out an album that's for this and
I thought I kind of had this and I felt
a calling a personal calling to this was
the time to step out and offer that
because I thought it could help frankly
and you know there's many ways to skin
the cat so it may be that you like some
other music that's all it's true there's
not one way to do it but I just found
from my own anecdotal experience that
this works quite well and so they're
having great results in these studies I
just thought maybe if you guys had a
slightly better artistic nuanced look at
the music aspect it could be even better
at her yeah it covered a lot of ground
they've covered it they did some studies
on what what works with musical flow
features but they never had like a
musicologist that i know of or musicians
artists saying here's here's the kind of
music instrumentation the flow the field
recordings coming and the nature sounds
all these things they don't have that
how did you end up figuring out what the
recipe was trial and error yeah yeah 10
years of trying things and seeing all
that works that doesn't work and in
intuition and being guided by the
mushrooms I suppose but that isn't very
scientific but just trying things and
and and guiding people and seeing what
works and after hundreds of people you
start to see patterns and you start to
learn and that's what you're
experiencing on that record it's kind of
where I'm at after a decade and then
there's like you said some field
recordings what else is in there it's
mostly comprised of different kinds of
pianos Fender Rhodes angelic vocals
nature field recording sounds some
flutes native flutes melodicas
hormone-iums some organ and it's all the
serve loop tea if you listen to it you
might think it was in a studio or that
it's multiple people but it's actually
just direct feed it into a recorder so
that's why you don't it sounds
you know I mean then doesn't sound live
but if if you're a musician you could
probably listen to it that guy to see
how that was live but it's a building in
layers but that's also again that came
out of the need for making music for
psilocybin and that was Annie but then
it didn't defined the type of music I
made but that was accident helping in
the psilocybin experience it's building
slowly the layers help the repetition of
certain musical phrases helps and train
your brain cuz you're all things that
help and those are modern sound healing
techniques combined with ancient sound
healing techniques of things if you go
to a lot of ayahuasca or Lakota sweat
lodges and so on they're all using music
as a central ceremonial vehicle and
they're doing it in a way that is been
done the same way for thousands of years
so you know it's like this guy just made
it up tonight I think that's how they've
been doing those songs forever so you
can learn what they learned and they can
see what they're doing musically is it
okay I'm gonna learn from that and try
to integrate that into this stuff what
do we know about modern sounding science
about brain entrainment or binary beats
or different tunings things like that
and what were your personal experiences
that led you it's even 10 years ago to
being like aha I think like a lot of
people and I had some psychedelic
experience as young my first one was
with mushrooms and I was in the 19 and
luckily and I say luckily because it was
luck it was positive and profoundly
positive and I went into a full ego
disillusioned but I didn't know I didn't
know anything I didn't know what it
meant even know what had just happened
but I knew it was profoundly amazing and
I spent a long time time to
reverse-engineer that and then it kind
of led to many mistakes and some
traumatic experiences and then having
some positive experiences with just
music in general and trying to and
really trying to recreate that but I
thought maybe I just need to make music
that I think would work for me in that
space and that's how this all started it
was just a tool for me and then I
started noticing it was working with
other people I had a friend
close friend who encouraged me to do
circles and ceremonies and I probably
would have done it without him he
literally pulled together yeah that's
some powerful moving the freaking theme
of the people that we sit down with us
that they had influences like that that
helped nudge them along and oh yeah I
mean my partner sitting right here I
mean and you know my partner before that
and oh and friends you've keep people
who are sort of there to encourage you
and because we're all just people we all
get down and we all get discouraged and
you're trying to do something that is
not encouraged by mainstream society or
really understood and there's a new wave
now but it's still the fringe well you
can see it somewhat changing in the last
year or two what is the relationship
between the indigenous people on the
planet and there are thousands of years
of practicing ceremony and the modern
movement towards ceremony well it's
interesting because each drug has its
own container for that that's different
so ayahuasca is unique because it's it's
kept retained inside at the ceremony
itself
you don't hear if people doing ayahuasca
recreation recreationally or outside of
an ayahuasca ceremony so it's really
interesting that like it's kept that as
part of it and never really left it and
I think that's part of the reasons for
its quote unquote success because it's
always in this ceremony as a setting
which helps it a lot it's very intense
experience and that keeps the music that
you're carros least if you're doing sort
of an amazonian style not the UDV or
something but even that's a ceremony and
then other drugs it's it's different I
mean Alice Dee was a creation so I mean
that in some ways that doesn't count
psilocybin had ritualistic use but it's
not as well-known and moreover it didn't
translate into Western society at all so
it's been for all intents and purpose
completely recreational so it didn't
have a musical tradition attached to it
and it certainly didn't have any I mean
most people that I talked to have
experienced mushrooms in their lives
at least once if not many times and
almost none of them have sat in ceremony
with them and then those who do come out
of it just be I had no idea of the death
hurry I had no idea how far I could go
with this medicine is such a profound
teacher and so ceremony comes in
different forms and shapes I think with
different plants and substances for
different reasons and but nonetheless
what you're finding like with you know
for instance peyote is inside a
container but then maybe mess glend
isn't oh yeah they're all different but
it the ceremony itself is a piece of
technology that is simple and powerful
and something it can be done and is done
outside of psychedelics all the time
it's a form of ritual you know writing a
check as a ritual brushing your teeth is
ritual making your coffee in the morning
as a form of ritual so it's about
intentionality is about how you focus
your consciousness it's about setting
setting and how you prime your your body
again it goes back to I set the
beginning about deciding what's sacred
because it's you say it is really what
else is it right it's just rituals about
how you arrange things in a way it's
about saying this is different this is
not mundane and so it's about choice the
power of ceremony and ritual in is a
technology that's a really good line
ABB's it's one of them you know original
technologies and it's a way of working
with your brain if you want to be really
it's flat about it but I like to say
your heart too but it's about what
either brain and and you could say
working to your ancestors all these
things but or if you wanted to stay very
scientific about it
it's a way of talking to these other
layers of our consciousness again
working with them and working with them
because you know trauma can live in the
body right
so some people have to have difficulty
like routing it out and getting over
certain traumatic acts because it's
living in the body or phantom pains and
things like this and these are just
different ways that we can get into
those places so psychedelics also dig
into these layers too so combining it
all into one soup makes a lot of sense
to me you have a lot of people know this
but I think likewise with our show it's
such a multidisciplinary show combining
it into one soup so tasty soup one
sausage yeah but with psilocybin it that
just happens to be sort of my person
that a lie and like I said it didn't
have that musical tradition and it
wasn't really couched into ceremony like
some other things like ayahuasca so I
was trying to coalesce that together a
bit because I think it's it is a little
more pervasive in some ways in American
culture but also the word psilocybin has
less baggage than LSD that's why I think
it's having some headway and like Denver
was decriminalized so forth because I
think many people don't even heard that
word so they don't have the instant oh
that story it's a new story your story
yes yeah but it's also been around in
the subculture for a long time and like
I said many people have experience with
it but not in ceremony so they haven't
unlocked in some ways the true power and
as a tool
I wonder where else practices of
ceremony and ritual can do what we need
geopolitically to get there that
exponential technology age maybe we ask
that question to you what do you see
with the artificial intelligence
synthetic biology age that we're going
through where do you see the play of
things like what you produce how we can
drive more unity and cohesion together
how do you see that working out well I
think about this usually from our music
perspective and I mean we could I don't
need to go into the trends I think where
the music industry might go with AI cuz
that's already happening like Spotify
playlist in it that's just the tip of
the iceberg but what I think people are
hungry for and will be more hungry for
and it's a symptom of the technological
rise and AI is for authentic experiences
for wisdom and for connection to
themselves or nature the planet they're
all the things we've had forever that
would sort of feel more separate from
through the use of technology and so
it's about decreasing that separateness
so I think the biggest one would be the
connection to nature and that's one of
the reasons I like putting the nature
field recordings that I record that
going out to wilderness places and bring
it into the music because it's a
reminder it's also a reflection of
yourself and it's it's a way of tapping
in you if we are the earth literally
we're made of it walking around talking
with eyes and areas and for some reason
we have engendered this feeling of
feeling not it a matter of fact I feel
like I'm myself and you're someone else
and that's that's where we're kind of
told and and that usually starts to
cultivate feelings of depression and and
also for its problems Wars and so forth
so I think that reconnection to nature
is something we had much more innately
and it was more mediate for millennia
yes but since the Industrial Revolution
particularly since the Information Age
it's been a rapid exponential decrease
of our connection to that which is
always around us the water that we are
in
fish yes we've forgotten what the water
is and we're like where's the water and
so we need these ways of to remind
ourselves and so for me like bringing in
that nature element it's all about
connecting back to what already is
because there's a solace in that
and I think so as the AI and all that
increases I think people be more and
more hungry for that so potentially one
of the best solutions remedies to the
issues that we're facing geopolitically
and with X motion technology is to
realize the water that the fish are in
is to unpeel what's already there it's
to take off the clothes we're wearing
that are hiding maybe our eyes because
the answers were looking for it's not a
new thing we're going to put on it's
going to things were going to take off
yeah for sure and we're just talking
about with somebody about house can't
they love seeing the Stars and how you
can't see the stars in the big cities
and that was a recent change right with
electricity essentially and then we
started having pollution and light at
night and we can't see it most people
don't see the star as much at night and
I live now in a place in southern Utah
at 7,000 feet with one of the darkest
places United States I see stars from
Horizon Horizon in the Milky Way oh it's
amazing but I just remember like that's
how it was for everybody all the time
forever forever and so there's a deep
relationship there's like the cosmos and
just said wait a minute
every night this humbleness and
questions and guidance and noticing and
that's been lost and again that's recent
so it's a sense of humbleness but in
that humbleness comes a sense of
connection and probably a lowering of
anxiety in these these are interesting
times just because there's so much
happening and changing and technology
and we just don't know we're all in it
together
you can't opt out anymore all right it's
not really practical to go to a cave and
even then you probably wouldn't be still
getting all the cell wires and all the
you know you can't opt out so you have
to just figure out how we're gonna get
through this thing together and we're
all trying what we know how to do one
step at a time
so the psychedelics are powerful tools
and I think that can be used for now
because we might not have 20 years to
sit in an ashram and wait for the answer
is just like what if you try to get a
few answers and in one evening yeah and
unless so let's try to make that safe
and let's try to it would if you have
some healing to do you know there's been
a lot of trauma from a lot of lot of
stuffs happened and a lot of people and
that just trickles down at the families
and abuse and all sorts of things it
just like it doesn't wave it's okay we
need to work and can you work with this
way to try to like let that water flow
down because it's so much right now and
so I think these we're starting to wake
up to tools that we've had for a long
time and now we're maybe like this
conference is thinking about how can we
use the technology and combine it with
this stuff and and maybe make it almost
like a surgical laser tool instead of
just willy-nilly rolling the dice that
always doesn't work out well would the
surgical laser tool look like for you
for me it's it's through music and
ceremony III think it's it's using old
tech in a fresh way in a modern context
so that's why it's creating music that
makes sense to us now like modern music
that's new shamanic American music is
that the Sun maybe exists and it's it's
something that's sort of backed up by
you do some daddy it's well just what
works and I think that's what that's
just kind of my angle with it it's for
some people it's biofeedback and
wearable tech but you could combine
these things know for sure when you
mentioned that a hundred billion humans
before us were able to observe the
cosmos and then the seven eight billion
alive now are unable to living in
Metropolis were in many ways where
going through a process of remembering
and reconnecting and like you said we
have these suits on these earth suits on
and so to peel back some of the layers
to see the way that we harmonize
together and do things like your music
as well east let's ask you about your
name
where did eased force to come from
that's easy it's just my last name is
Oswalt and that's German and O's is East
and fault is forest so it's just another
way of saying my name so there's not
much of it I feel like it has a feeling
to it because it has the word East which
feels like Eastern forest has a certain
vibe but that just happened it yeah I
mean I I noticed it and I liked it that
like Oh that'd be a great way to
describe this music I was making but
yeah it's not like I pulled it out of
some way some branding how does one go
about renouncing their birth name and
going with the new identity because I
know several people follow something
suit like that and it's hard for others
to make the transition yeah I don't know
I mean for me I don't identify as East
Forest and some people call me east for
East force and it's fine but I I did
take on a new name recently and I was
Krishna my name is Trevor and birth name
and I did that though is sort of easy
for me because it was given to me and by
someone I really respected so it's like
it wasn't like I decided that I didn't
have some a journey was like I want to
be called Krishna it's more like someone
says you know if I were to give you I'm
giving you spiritual name and it's
Krishna and there's someone I couldn't
they argue with I'm like okay now I
could just have that but I thought it
was an opportunity to identify sort of
with a new pair of clothes and it was a
really beautiful opportunity at 40 years
old to say well what if I tried what it
felt like to identify what I think that
name means what would that feel like it
was an opportunity to step into
something larger
that maybe I didn't feel worthy or I
didn't feel adequate right I had all the
other baggage with the other name I'm
not throwing anything away and that's
what's fun about it too to recognize
it's just a name it's just a word that
someone's just like hey call me that I
know okay
most people don't care it really is just
about how it makes me feel and it helps
me step up to the plate in a way that is
probably just gonna be more loving and
so it's just a way for someone he saw in
me something larger that I saw in myself
and that was just being in he by doing
that he was being very loving and that
was amazing
hope you step up to the plate like that
there's still a lot more to discuss
let's ask you two quick questions on the
way out of the show the first question
is are we in a simulation I don't know
if it is if we are it's a really good
one and I don't think so
I really don't but I know some people
have argued that it's an interesting
argument and I wouldn't say it's
impossible but my heart says no and if
it's true I'm gonna be a little
heartbroken but either way the
experience I'm having here is so
incredible and rich that it still feels
important to me and I would say then
what's the inside what's the simulation
inside the simulation or or we still is
still got or still the universe I mean I
think a lot about what's outside the
universe so or is there an outside or
what does it even mean so we can see
these things to some degree I'm saying
we can see the universe expanding we
could see old galaxies new galaxies we
can see the spaciousness but it's like
but there has to be something past what
we can see or what does that even mean I
don't know but it's an amazing thing
I mean psychedelics also start to show
you this kind of infinite quality of
circles within circles within circles in
the same way that people come out of
people a lot of people that come out
literally of the holes of people and
so there's we often see on this planet
so above our as above so below with
whether it's atoms to galaxies and
structures and the golden ratio so if
you want to just trust in what we see it
would seem that systems are within
systems are within systems forever it's
hard to say but it looks to be that way
but I certainly don't know so if anyone
tells you they know red flag and then
last question is what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world
forgiveness and and love the fact that
people can love you and forgive you in
that humaneness and ability to love you
in the face of all this absurdity and
mistakes is beautiful it really is and
that's this the human capacity for love
that I'm sure it's mirrored and animals
and noises but we have we think about it
more at least I do too much Jesus has
been such a good conversation thank you
very much for coming at rocket to us
really appreciate it
yeah and thank you for the incredible
performance this morning and for
tomorrow's we're really excited for
thanks I'm glad enough to get to play
that's why I saw room what where the
links that people can find you at at
East Forest org east force org links my
bio yeah and that's social medias or
it's either east forest or east forest
music East for series for some music on
social media you can find those links
below and then is the album also on yeah
I'm sorry yeah the ROM does record and
the music for mushrooms record or both
on the website or anywhere you listen to
music Spotify iTunes everywhere
wonderful okay wonderful all the links
are in the bio everyone check those out
also support people like east also
support consciousness hacking support
simulation of the artists entrepreneurs
organizations around the world that you
believe in the links are below and also
talk to your friends your families your
co-workers people online on social media
more about exactly what we talked about
on the show get more conversations
rollin about it and go and build a few
sure everyone manifest your dreams into
the world thank you so much for tuning
in and we will see you soon